Hello?
Just waiting to confirm. I can hear myself.
And I can. Awesome.
Hello,
everyone.
So today's
session,
we're gonna continue to monitor stuff with InfluxDB.
No surprises there.
And what we're gonna look at today
is Docker Swarm.
I have not
touched Docker Swarm in three years,
maybe a little bit longer,
but I'm hoping that not too much has
changed. So we're just gonna get started. We're
gonna go for the zero to hero approach,
hopefully not zero to failure,
where I configure my local machine with Docker
Swarm. We spin up
InfluxDB
two, and we start scraping as many metrics
as can. I'll try and keep this similar
to my Kubernetes
examples and that
we we really wanna be able to build
a dashboard that allows us to have some
level of proactive operate operations
and really good alerting,
which means we will be focusing on
failures and reconciliation and how we can notify
ourselves when that is the case.
So let's see.
We have
an empty directory
with a nada, nothing
in it whatsoever.
We have a terminal
with no magic either.
Hopefully, I have no containers running.
Good.
Hopefully, Docker Swarm still exists. It does. And
hopefully,
running in it is all I need.
Good. I mean, the style is simple as
ever, which is
awesome.
And
let's see if we can just get InfluxDB
deployed pretty quickly then. I don't see there
being too many hurdles.
I don't know what the latest version is.
There is a good point.
We'll just use three without specifying any point
version and we'll see what happens.
We wanted to find a service,
InfluxDB
and we're gonna use InfluxDB two today,
which is in beta
and should be deployable like so.
We want to expose
port nine nine nine nine so that we
can actually browse to our InfluxDB.
Do I care about persistence?
I mean, it doesn't hurt. It'll seem we're
doing any sub commands.
What was the syntax on this again? Let's
see.
InfluxDB
data.
I'm pretty sure that just means local
volumes
and
we want influx oh, this is a list.
So InfluxDB
So InfluxDB two stores data and the user's
root.
Not not great, but well, it's a beta.
That's what we're dealing with.
So what else do I need here?
I think
that's it.
Let's do tests. So now that we have
a swarm cluster,
I can't like I said, I've not used
swarm in many years.
So we're just gonna try and spin this
up.
Background.
Okay.
DC down.
So we want you to a stack to
play.
Compose fail.
I mean, that should be defaulted.
Alright. When in doubt, here's the docs.
And so we want do docker start deploy
where we compose fail
and we wanna specify that. We don't need
to specify an orchestrator, I would imagine.
Yes.
Okay. So what is wrong with
dash c docker
or
data stack name
demo?
Yep. Thank you for the assist there. Stack
needs a name.
Yeah. So there was a question saying that
this tells that here looks wrong.
This just means use the default options
which configures
a
bind mount with the host. It's the same
as using a named volume on the Docker
container run command.
I use that all the time with Docker
Compose local.
I have no idea whether that's gonna work
in swarm mode,
but we do have something deployed. So let's
let's just see what's happening first.
Oh, don't open that. Okay. So
it does look like InfluxDB is running.
Let's see what's going on with
the volume then. So let's do 48.
And it works. Go away. Config.
No. You can't see volumes there, can you?
Manage.
Yeah. Okay. So we did get an in
volume by using the tilde.
I mean, if I were running more than
one node,
probably that's what I feel if it has
to be rescheduled. I'm sure there's a really
nice way of doing this in swarm mode,
but learning the volume implementation is not something
I think I wanna try and do today.
So I'm quite happy just to leverage this
name volume and just say, hey. Magic. It
works.
Alright.
Let's see. Can we browse to this then?
Computer maybe saying no.
Alright.
Let's
take a look at that container l s
again.
Alright. So exposing
pores
like I normally would
does not work.
I guess that makes sense.
So let's look up
the format.
I'm sure there is
something that I need to publish,
expose
at oh, 3.8. Alright. I'll probably bump up
to that too then.
Those ports that publishing them to the host
machine.
Nope. Don't want that.
Ports. Okay. So this syntax is slightly
different, not available since 3.2.
And
yep. So we want host mode so that
we can
close this on Docker Swarm.
Nice.
So
let's just
paste this in
and
99999999.
And we don't need to use more than
n grids because we only have a single
host.
Okay. Let's
update this because we said we would I
said it would do 3.8. I don't know
what the differences are,
but we'll work it out as we go.
So in order to redeploy this, I'm assuming,
I just run this and Docker is gonna
do its magic.
Oh, it's definitely broken there. Nope. Nope. There
we go. Okay. So what are my swarming
commands? What have I got? The services everything?
Nope.
Docker
form.
Alright. That's that's just the management stuff.
I wonder if I I just want to
know if I can view my container. We
take their container l s, but something that's
more
for me.
I guess it's not particularly important. We do
have the container running now.
This looks much better with regards to publishing.
So
Nice.
We now have access to InfluxDB.
So let's set up my user.
We'll just call this default.
Oh,
cool.
I'm an expert. Thank you very much. Alright.
So we have my bucket.
So good progress. We've got Swarm running, InfluxDB
running,
and now we wanna understand
from a metrics point of view what is
going on here.
But I think what I'm gonna do first
is
local
host.
It's 2375
and see if there's a metrics
endpoint.
No.
Port does it even run on again?
Docker.
Yep. Useful.
Two three eight five. Am I just am
I to draw?
No. I'm just very wrong. Okay. Docker
daemon
four.
Two three seven six.
I really should stop guessing.
I know what to do. Let's just run
Telegraph.
So Telegraph is the agent collection agent that
works with pretty much every time series database.
It is by the same company that produce
InfluxDB,
so the support there is really good as
well.
But this will speak over Docker stock at
RTCP
hopefully grab the metrics.
I just assumed
the Docker daemon would maybe spout some Prometheus
metrics. Maybe it does.
So we have a comment that the metrics
are possibly not on by default. Alright. Okay.
No problem. Thank you for that. So we're
just going to copy this example config and
then work out what we need. So
let's create our telegraph
dot conf agent.
Let's have a interval of five seconds,
flush interval,
five seconds. Now that just means scrape the
metrics every five seconds and write them to
the database every five seconds.
We then want to enable,
inputs docker plug in
and
we're not gonna use the socket because we're
gonna run this.
I can't just run it on a host,
can I?
No. Let's deploy it. So TCP,
I don't know if I deploy it, I
won't have access to the daemon. There we
go.
That'll do.
Gather services.
Alright. Nice. So it's even got some swarm
stuff going on here.
So let's say yes to that.
Container names. Yep. Stupid setting.
Source tag.
So set the source tag for metrics to
the container ID host name.
I don't know if we need that yet.
We'll come back to that one.
Let's not include or exclude anything.
Timer,
choose a default.
Pair device, where I have to report for
each container, device block IO and network stats
are not. Well, yeah, I think so. Where
I should report for each container total block
IO or network status or not.
Yeah. False. True. Okay.
Don't need this.
Don't care about that. And don't care about
that. Nice. Okay.
Now
before I rewrite this to InfluxDB,
I'm going to just run it locally, output
into a file,
standard out specifically so that I can see
what I get back.
I'm gonna run telegraph,
point it to this config,
wait five seconds, it's gonna spit some stuff
out and we'll see what we have.
We have lots.
Alright.
Cool.
Let's trace it to InfluxDB then.
I guess that was pretty easy.
No. Outputs.
InfluxDB
v two URLs
equals so our InfluxDB,
if I run telegraph locally so I can
use the Docker socket other than TCP,
then
InfluxDB
will be available on 1 to 79999.
We need to specify the organization,
which I believe I made my username.
The bucket, I believe I called the file.
We will need a token, which we have
not lifted yet. So let's come into here
and grab our token.
Cool.
Now rather than
logging up that terminal, I would just leave
Telegraph
running
here.
I'm gonna wait five seconds to confirm that
it can write to my Influx and then
close this tab and forget about it.
There you got it.
Okay.
No errors,
which means
we have metrics.
Sweet.
So let's see. What have we got?
We've got the total
memory
as it's on the machine,
which means
if I
pop open this
with max usage
max
usage is now blue.
Cool.
We have the number of containers.
So let's
also break that down. So click go.
We've got five containers,
four stopped,
one running,
zero paused.
Cool.
Number of images.
I have 20 images.
Failed descriptors.
Yeah. Whatever. What else we got?
We've got disk IO stats. Let's avoid that
for now. We've got CPU.
Let's see.
We got
usage stats.
You see that going up as I'm playing
around with Influx.
Cool. Let's jump into memory.
Let's have a look at that.
Resetual set size,
cash
usage, j c percent.
That'll be pretty standard.
Okay.
Now let's see if we can take a
look at some of that swarmy stuff. This
is just all,
you know, standard Docker stuff. There's a dashboard
we can import.
Hopefully, it gives us a pretty good look
at all of that
network stuff,
container statuses,
cool, and then this.
Is this?
Not a lot
of information we're gonna get out of that.
It looks like we may have to kind
of
pry the metrics out of Docker Swarm or
find out how to chart on something a
bit more substantial from the service layer.
Although, I guess, I mean, I'm used to
the Kubernetes
metrics. There's a lot of moving parts in
Kubernetes. Swarm is much simpler. I mean, maybe
that's all you need, Fluke. Is my running
different from my desired?
Send in a letter.
We'll play around with that in a minute.
We'll maybe try and
put some resource limits
or reserve some resource for pods pods
for containers that don't need it and see
what happens when we try and schedule more.
Yeah. Let me think about that. We'll come
up with some failure scenarios.
Now because this is a new InfluxDB,
we have no dashboards,
so we're going to
import some dashboards.
Let's get
a community
template.
Has anyone done
or created a docker
dashboard?
Good.
Alright.
Let us apply this. So
we paste this command in. That's gonna fail.
We need some authentication credentials,
so
we're gonna use the org here.
We also need a token,
which we'll just apply globally
and I will copy that once more
and really keep that handy.
Copy it
and apply. We get this big preview
by shrinking my font down.
You can just see that it's creating some
labels,
creating a telegraph config for us and some
dashboards.
Yes. Okay. That
pop this back again.
Come over here.
And Why did it create a bucket called
dev?
Did I do that?
Let's create a bucket called docker.
I don't think templates should create buckets. I
need to feed that back.
Where did Dave come from?
Well, that needs
fixed
anyway.
So we're we don't have a docker bucket,
but we do have a default bucket. So
we've got some stats working.
That's good.
We don't have anything for number of images.
Let's just run this manually,
see what's broken.
So,
ah, it's got a hard coded bucket name.
It would appear there are numerous problems
with this template,
but nothing we can't fix.
Somebody remind me to send a PR to
this repo.
V bucket
run.
Good.
Good. Alright.
Do I really wanna go and fix all
of these?
We should, shouldn't we?
So this is
this is okay. So this is looking for
metrics from
a different plugin that's not Docker.
And I think if we take a look
inside here, it did create a telegraph config.
And if we just pop down,
we'll actually be able to see the inputs
the dashboard wants us to use. Now I
didn't use this this config, perhaps I should
have.
We've got total and that on, so maybe
I'll steal a bit of that. But what
I want just now
is these missing plugins to give me the
extra
metrics that we want. So these are just
host level metrics.
So plugins that we have here, let's just
and then this properly.
We have the CPU plugin. We've got the
desk IO plugin.
Yeah. We're gonna ignore
random desks that we don't care about, temp
dev squash overlays.
We're also pulling in and puts some metrics
for our disk IO, kernel, mem, net, process,
and swapping system. I mean, this is pretty
much if you wanna do Linux system monitoring,
this is the exact plugins that you should
be running, so that's great.
So we just kill telegraph, spin that back
up, put the new config,
maybe turn that back on later. I'm not
particularly fast and let's just quickly run through
any missing
bucket changes. These all seem okay. I think
it's just we need to wait for that
data to come in.
So let's hit refresh.
Cool. Much better.
I'll accept this white space.
It'll bug me.
Okay. So this dashboard gives us an overview
of docker metrics. Right? Then we've got the
daemon, number of images.
I don't think I'd ever really
I mean, I don't really care how many
images are on my host. I'd actually I'm
probably more interested in how much disk
the images are consuming.
I'm curious if we can get that metric.
So let's let's see.
So Docker.
Uh-huh. This one.
Oh, we've got number of images.
I don't think it exposes the size
of those images.
I wonder if that's something that Docker doesn't
expose to its metrics endpoint or just something
that the Telegraph plugin
isn't consuming.
I'll maybe do a wee creative Google on
docker metrics in a minute.
We can always send a PR to Telegraph
to try and make this a bit more
all encapsulated.
Alright. So total number of containers.
Yeah. I mean, I I definitely probably wanna
keep an eye on how many containers are
running on my machine.
More so, I wanna track the CPU and
memory, but we'll come back to that in
a minute.
Number of running containers.
Yep.
Standard.
Yep. I have an eight core machine and
16 gig of RAM.
Okay. System status. Yep. I reboot my computer
almost
every day.
My uptime never gets long.
My load average is a little bit higher
than I would like, but I am streaming.
What we should should hopefully be zero. Yep.
What do we got here? System load. That's
gonna chop and change. Let's stick this on
a refresh.
I mean, as we do more stuff, spin
up more containers, we'll see that fluctuate. Same
with the CPU usage.
Memory usage, I'm at 20%. Happy with that.
Network.
See.
This is pair container.
That's my one container that I have running.
And that's just gonna be the actual data
that's been streamed to this dashboard, to the
host.
We can maybe try and inflate that, run
a few commands inside the container
and try and, you know, call some spikes,
do some alerting.
Then we have the disk usage.
Of course, this is gonna increase pretty linear
because I'm writing the same number of metrics
every five seconds.
So I would expect this not to fluctuate
too much. Obviously, there was a telegraph restart.
Is that what that is? Yeah. I think
so.
Everything
came back up. So that would
it was like
this.
Yeah. I have no idea what's going on
here.
That's a good time.
I'll work that out in a minute.
Okay. Memory consumption is going up. Wouldn't have
expected that.
Although, we are streaming stats to this dashboard,
so Flux will be caching some of these
metrics and memory.
Maybe there would be a small increase here.
Okay. We've got some information.
I think let's just
take this a little bit further. Let's just
grab the Linux template too,
and that gives us a pretty complete look
at my laptop.
Okay. So
let's just grab this command and change
the URL.
Oops.
We don't need to start that again.
Go.
And we come to dashboards. We now have
Linux system.
Let's do five minutes. I'll refresh
and default bucket.
Perfect.
Okay.
Good progress. I like this.
But we're not
we don't really have a complete look at
what's going on.
I wonder if we could deploy so my
thought process right now is let's deploy
a rogue container,
either one that's gonna fill my desk or
eat my RAM. In fact, let's not eat
my RAM. It may affect the stream. I've
done that before.
We'll maybe try and consume some disk, maybe
a container run-in DD
right into file
or meg increments,
see what happens.
Try and all that on that. We also
wanted to play some failed containers.
So let's try and simulate that first.
So if we come back to the compose
file,
let's assume
we have
command
not found
image,
Alpine 3.9,
Entry point of
ash, but spelled wrongly.
And restart
always.
In fact, let's not do always just yeah.
Maybe.
Yeah. Let's just do always.
I was gonna say maybe we'll do our
on failure of a max retries to see
that stop trying to be rescheduled.
But I'll need to look up the Compose
syntax for that. And I don't know how
Compose handles it. Like, Kubernetes would do a
crash loop back off, some sort of exponential
back off before it keeps obviously trying to
fix the reconciliation.
I have no idea what Swarm is gonna
do. So
let's
stack
deploy.
Restart.
I guess we're looking up that syntax a
little bit quicker.
Docker
compose
config.
Anyone who's watching,
if there are questions that you want this
dashboard to answer,
especially if you have any sort of swarm
experience, now is the time to put those
in the chat and I will make sure
I cover them all.
Okay.
So
retry and I'll restart
policy.
How do you set a limit?
Oh, let's just put it in.
What did I get wrong there?
Okay. So we have some deploy configuration.
Alright. Okay. It's it's kept separate from the
old composed stuff. Okay. Got it.
Well, we run container l s. It did
take a few seconds last time.
So
no watches there.
But it will be failing, so
yep. There we go. Alpine, Alpine, Alpine, fail,
fail,
And what does that look like from a
metrics point of view then?
Okay. So our number of containers is gonna
continually increase
every time that gets created and fails to
start,
but our number of running containers is never
gonna increase. So there's
definitely something that shows us. There's
a letter in potential there.
And I'll that did clean up one or
two there. What
about
okay.
So
I guess what we found out now is
that this dashboard
is very much
just for Docker daemon without swarm mode. So
I think what we really wanna do
is just create another one.
Let's call this our swarm
dashboard.
And what I wanna add first is
anything that tells me
this is broken.
And we already seen those two stats earlier,
so let's get them sorted. So we're gonna
come into our explorer view.
We're gonna click on swarm and we want
both of these values
over the last five minutes.
And what we have here
is
zero
running.
Hold on, let me view the raw data.
The tasks desired
and FlexVP
And there we go. Task desired one
and if
task running
zero. Okay. Why is that visible
here?
Okay. Let's just view one at a time.
Okay. So task running zero
and if I filter
task desired.
Oh, where's my desired for
Oh, that side is looking weird.
Okay. Script editor time.
View raw data.
Let's
just grab
many tables do we have? We've got one,
so that's one for each docker image.
Now, we only wanna grab
the last value pair table,
flatten those tables,
in fact, that'll be enough.
And that's just the last knowing state or
desired value state for each of our service
names. So for anyone who's not familiar with
InfluxDB two and Flux,
let me quickly run over what the hell
just happened there. So
we pull from a bucket, which is just
like a database or table and any other
kind of
general database.
We have this range statement which just says
show me values at start and stop. So
anything in between these and the start and
stop is based on the selector here.
We're filtering on only the swarm measurements and
we're just looking at one field, which is
tasks desired.
Then because these metrics are emitted every five
seconds, we're gonna see a value every five
seconds here and we get a different table
for each series.
A series
is
based on the group key,
which by default is all of the tags.
Now because the service name is a tag
and we have two values for that tag,
we get back two tables.
What we'll see if I scroll down here,
this is gonna be table zero and this
will be table one because these values change.
Now we don't care about every single point
every five seconds for the last five minutes.
So we're gonna last that, which means we
get back two points.
Table zero for the last point on InfluxDB
and table one is the last point for
demo command not found.
We can then use an empty group key
to flatten that to a single table
and we get back to this data like
this.
Now that won't be
something we can do here.
If we remove this group,
it will be because we have two unique
CDs, but we only have one point. So
when I do something like this, what I
actually
want to do is
we usually work with a a single stat,
some sort of
panel that just says these are how many
containers that we desire.
So I'm going to bring in a sense
to flatten it, and the reason I flatten
it is that I can now sum.
And now I get a single value that
says we have two containers
desired.
And what I wanna do is
single stat,
turn off this,
and we have that.
So
containers
desired.
Tasks, sorry,
warm chat tasks.
So let's clone this
and
let's have tasks
running.
What was that field called?
Usually the auto complete works on the data.
I'm not sure what's going on there.
Tasks.
Yeah. There we go. Task running.
Now,
at a glance, we have this indicator that
says, hey, these values are not the same.
Let's see if we can make that slightly
more visual now. So
we're gonna have a nice big graph
to show the discrepancy over time.
What
we're gonna I guess, I mean,
from any orchestration system, there are going to
be
differences between actual and desired state.
It's not a problem until that, you know,
that difference has been running for too long.
So,
let's
get back down to graph
graphable view.
And
what we want now
let's get rid of this. Let's just graph
it for now. Maybe do something with that
single stat layer.
So we can very much see these lines
are parallel. Right? Desired state has never
been realized.
In fact, we're only yeah. Wait. What? Yeah.
We've got that running and that is running
as the needle.
Let's not filter on that field,
bring in everything.
Let's calculate.
Let's try and do something weird. This
is
this is my problem on these streams is
that I have random ideas in my head
and I think, wonder if I can make
this work. But what I wanna do is
pull out these points,
actually calculate
the the difference
between desired and actual for each
task
so that
either a container being rescheduled
or failing
should show as a blip on a graph
rather than parallel lanes.
So let's see if we can make that
work.
Let's get a view data so I know
what I'm working with.
I need to change the group key. So
what we're gonna see we've seen earlier we
had two tables. Right? We had
because we're only filtering on a single field,
the only thing that changed per table was
the value of
a tag, which was just the task name
or service name.
Now we should see four.
Yeah.
You know, one, two, and three. And that's
because the field is also part of the
group key and that changes. So our field
here is task desired
and then we have task running.
Let's what we we want two tables, one
per series and both of those fields available
to us so that we can map over
them,
do the subtraction
hopefully.
To be honest, I've had a lot of
problems trying to do
some of these operations in Flux
but I'm confident.
I'm sure that's an incompetent.
So
change the group key,
columns.
We wanna group on
our measurement.
So
the fact that we're creating Docker Swarm, we
want to group on
I mean, the host isn't important, but it
doesn't change, so we just throw it in
there
and
the service
ID.
I should have two tables.
Inside of those tables,
multiple
fields.
Yes.
We wanna pivot from a columnar structure
to a row based structure.
So our column key
is
build.
Our row key
is service ID.
Yeah. We want to make rows where the
service ID is the same.
We identify columns to be pivoted
by field
and our value
is a value.
Nice.
And now we have two tables
and we have our tasks desired
and our tasks
running.
But I have lost
time.
So we still want points
we still want multiple multiple records
per table with the time.
And that just means I need my group
key to include time.
So
let's
add
10.
Okay.
We're getting there.
We want this I want the service name
to right. I don't wanna work with that
service ID that we have there.
Okay. Service names.
So now we have these.
Because the group key
includes the time, that means we're gonna get
a table for every entry.
So
now that we've pivoted that, we can then
regroup again.
I know this is
pretty confusing.
It
just takes a little bit of time and
patience
to kinda get used to it.
So
we want to then we basically just wanna
copy this but remove time,
But we wanted the records to survive the
pivot.
I hope that makes sense. If not,
I can go over that again.
Good. So now table zero is always going
to be our InfluxDB service name. These are
the values every five seconds.
And when we get to table one,
it's this one, but the same. So this
should be graphable.
Kinda.
So now what we want to do is
map over
each of these points
and def these two integers.
So we're gonna do a map which takes
a function.
And what we want to do is
r web, so record web a new value
called def,
which is equal to r
tasks
desired,
which should always be the same or higher
than tasks
running.
Will it?
I guess if I scaled down,
we can deal with the odd negative integer.
Right?
Minus
our tasks
running.
Oh, what did I get wrong?
How does the web syntax work again?
Are with
When in doubt,
docs.
Let's see. Do we have an example in
that
with
oh, we do. With
oh,
broke it.
Go back to map.
Where?
Spell.
There you go.
Alright. With nuke. Yeah. That's what I've got.
Right?
Does it just want me to
block that off? Yeah. Okay.
So we should have an extra column,
which is always gonna be zero for InfluxDB,
but I'm hoping
yeah. For command not found, we now have
an indicator that, hey, we've been trying to
schedule one or more
containers.
Alright. What else do we need?
We wanna rename this value
so we can graph it.
Well hopefully
good.
We still got parallel lanes, but we now
have the context that means anything above zero
is bad.
Can we clean up this chart in any
way
just to make
it easier?
Not really much.
I mean, I could set
this to be, you know,
10.
This gives us a bit more
I don't know. I think that's gonna be
easier to consume
but we're set as max limit that we
don't really want.
I don't really want it broken down
to units less than one,
but
I just don't think I can configure that
in any way.
Yeah. We'll just need to make our piece
of it for now. I guess we can
always, deploy a few extra workloads,
see what happens.
Why did that crash there? Ah, there we
go.
Okay.
So these are interesting. I didn't expect
did we not make this running?
No.
There we go.
Okay. So we have a Docker Swarm dashboard.
I can see tasks desired two, tasks running
one and I have a graph that shows
me
hey, this has been running pretty poorly for
at least five minutes.
And we set this to an hour.
Okay. So our data is there we go.
It's not been doing this an hour. So
fifteen minutes. Yeah. It's been broken the entire
time.
So let's just fix it so we can
see that graph work in a healthy fashion.
Now if I just do sleep
command because, you know, Docker fucked up that
syntax.
I
don't mean that too much.
Docker stack deploy.
That container should be happy running it asleep.
Yep.
Give that five seconds.
Good.
Graph is happy.
So before
we
go and look into
the
I I think there's potential metrics that Docker
Swarm is exposing that we're not consuming on
a Telegraph plugin.
And I wanna dig into that a little
bit. I would love to understand
if we can get stuff like
the total amount of disk being consumed by
images
and volumes.
Maybe that is available. I'll I'll double check
before I waste any time on that. But
I wanna do an alert and example on
just this reconciliation.
Then
we will maybe dig into something else for
ten or fifteen minutes.
I've not had any questions about things that
they want this dashboard to answer. I'm assuming
I mean, this is the big one. Right?
Any orchestration system is the same as when
does my desired state deviate from the the
actual state.
And that's what I wanna alert on, especially
if it's been that way for a certain
predefined set of time.
Like, I expect my desired state and my
actual state
to be different for a very short period
of time and you can decide what that
that level of safety is.
So let's alert.
There's a really cool website called rbox.app,
which just allows you to create an HTTP
endpoint.
I'm gonna use this to receive my alerts.
Now
InfluxDB two ships with built in alerting,
which will also be exported to YAML
when I export this dashboard.
Oh, in fact, these are these have already
been imported
from one of those two different
package community templates that I imported. I don't
know which.
And it created an HTTP post on local
host alert. Well, I mean, that's gonna fail.
Let's turn that off.
So we could use Slack or PagerDuty.
I'm more than happy to use our box
for the time being.
We're gonna send a post request to this
location and click go.
I wanna create a first dead man alert,
which will trigger by killing telegraph.
And what we're gonna see is when we
stop receiving metrics
from Docker Swarm,
then that is bad.
I should have named it.
So Docker
Swarm
state.
We're gonna schedule this every fifteen seconds.
We don't need an offset.
We'll just add a tag of docker
one.
And if I don't get these two values
for
two windows,
thirty seconds,
which I know is probably a bit hasty,
we'll set the status to critical. In fact,
no, we'll set it to warn
and stop checking after five
minutes, you know. If nobody has
five minutes to critical.
Yeah. If we don't get a value for
two missing windows,
notify the world.
Something else that I wanna create
is my threshold check
where
these two values
oh, can I not rate flux here?
That's not gonna work. That's annoying.
Why can I not rate flux?
Okay. So our threshold check isn't gonna allow
us to let us do the math that
we want. However,
I have a plan.
So it's quick. If when anything goes to
critical, schedule every
thirty seconds,
please
use this RBOX one. Go. Thanks.
If I wanted to filter this purely on
the Docker Swarm,
I can do Docker
Swarm,
and I can have my other alerts
not filter on that tag.
Okay.
Let's quickly go back to my dashboard. I
wanna copy my query from here.
And what I'm gonna do is
write a task.
Let me think this through.
So
alert
on
desired
versus
actual
state.
We're gonna run every thirty seconds
and
we're gonna fetch
thirty seconds
for the metrics.
We've created a new field.
Now we have two options.
We can either
use this as a
tutorial of downsampling data writing it back
into the bucket,
or we trigger the alert straight from here.
I've never I've never done either,
but I'm gonna use that same confidence I
had earlier. So
if we want to send an HTTP alert,
what we need to do is import HTTP.
We can
instead
of
let's push this down.
Comment it out. If
we open a block
and see
if our
tasks desired
minus r
tasks
running
greater
than zero.
I can't even remember.
Let's check this out. Conditionals.
F then. Oh, it's just f then. Yeah.
Go on.
So f
then
can I do it with something else?
Okay.
And then else
false.
And but the and then is gonna be
that we want to do an HTTP
post
URL.
How can we make it a shot up?
Yep. At least I got one bit right.
Copy you.
And we don't need that across multiple lines.
Why are you mulling at me? What have
I got wrong? Expected rate per annum.
Yep.
Why are you mulling?
Ev.
What? I just bet you're talking for property
key ev. Alright. Let's try and simplify this
first. So
if true,
then
true,
else false.
Like that.
No. Alright.
Let's look out conditionals again.
Here's a nice example.
A little color doesn't exist.
That's gonna fill
green equals equals green.
Oh, wait. This is object syntax.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. So you can use
like like we did with our web to
add new fields to a dictionary map, whatever
you wanna call it. I mean, this is
a this is a map.
You gotta be careful with the way and
I just obviously still really poor at it.
But the way you had a multilane functions
yeah.
Just too much
using other languages.
Okay. So now we should have ever our
task desired minus our tasks running as greater
than zero. We send a alert
to this end point.
And we don't need headers.
And we're gonna send some data and what
we want to send is we're gonna JSON
encode some stuff.
So JSON encode
b equals blah, which means we have to
import
JSON.
And
what we're going to send here
is
can I just do a dict where I
see the service name
and use our
service
name?
Let's also include desired,
which is our
tasks
desired.
Oh, what have I got wrong? Oh, yeah.
I haven't closed that one off.
I have no idea what that means.
Delete.
Oh, wait. I've got too many things. There
we go.
And we'll send actual.
So r
like that,
which is tasks
running.
Otherwise, don't do anything.
We don't need to do anything with this
data,
but assuming I get this to work, we
will try
and do the alternative approach of downsampling in
the data, writing it into
a bucket so that we have the
the deviation value as part of the values
we can fetch in the threshold check and
if that threshold check fails for too long
where the deviation
is above zero,
we'll alert using the actual built in alerting
the system.
I think, Oh, it's not. I mean, I
know I would always encourage you to
create projections and aggregates and tasks, write them
back, and then alert on those values rather
than this. This is kind of a back
and dirty. Let's just get an alert running
approach.
Okay.
I found a bull. Why have I got
oh, yeah. Because of this. Okay. I just
returned zero.
Perfect.
So this task will start running within thirty
seconds.
We do have something above zero
so
just a reminder. No, we don't. We fixed
it.
Healthy graph, there is no shade.
Let's break it once more
and we're gonna break it.
We can just add another e here
and do our stack deploy.
Awesome.
Give this five seconds. Get that spake back
up. Within a minute, we should have an
alert which should hopefully be hitting this endpoint.
Still nothing yet.
And once I see this spike here, I'll
come back and we'll attempt the downsample aggregation
approach
and then use the threshold check, and then
I'm gonna call it quits.
Okay. So we have our failure identified.
Nothing yet, but should hopefully be less than
a minute.
Let's come back to our task and I'm
gonna duplicate this.
Just disable it while I work on it.
Oh, wait. That was that one.
Surely that's a bug.
Is it deactivating
based on name?
No.
That was weird.
Okay.
So this task is aggregate
deviation of desired state.
So we don't want
to trigger less,
and we can let that be generated when
we save it and
we do not want
this anymore. Instead, we want to add a
value.
So r
with
deviation.
How do spell deviation? Yeah.
R tasks
desired
minus r
tasks
running.
Close.
And
we wanna write this data.
See if I can remember how to do
that. So
there is a two function.
That's not the Flux docs anymore.
Dot two.
Alright. Let's find it.
Where we write the data.
So
once we've mapped it,
we probably wanna do a filter
and
we want to only find our
deviation
greater than zero.
I've got a problem here.
And when we had that last time,
just
that worked.
So we've added our filter.
Is that right? Yep.
And now we wanna do a two.
We're gonna write to the same bucket
and the same organization.
10 columns gonna be the same.
No. The tags, we don't wanna ruin the
tags.
So
we're gonna match our group key. So measurement,
which I think is actually implicit,
so that may cause an error, but we'll
see in a moment.
Service
name.
Field function.
What's that?
I wonder if we wanna use experimental too.
So there's an experimental too function too.
That's a weird sentence, but I've not used
either. I wonder if it simplifies that. Yeah.
Let's just do that.
I mean, that could work,
but it just seems like too much work.
So
I think I need to import experimental.
And I think it just
magically does stuff with that data. We're gonna
think though. I'm not entirely sure.
This stuff changes a lot.
I think
that might be it. One thing I am
gonna do is
try and match my five second interval with
the raw data.
Not something you would normally no. It's not
something you would I'm not gonna do that.
I mean, I could do it, which would
give me an ability to graph it the
same way I am before, but I I
just I don't think I need that resolution.
So and I don't need to complicate myself
right now by thinking about it.
Alright. Unable to edit option. I didn't edit
the option.
I did remove the option, but that's because
I changed this.
Yeah. So
initially saved with an option and it's not
gonna let me remove it.
I guess that's nice of it. So let
me cancel, jump back in, copy this,
and we'll leave the option.
Like so.
I'm still gonna change the name, so
aggregate
deviated state.
I don't know if that'll update the option
for me.
Yeah. Good. Okay.
So let's turn that on.
There we go.
We don't have anything here. Okay. So let's
try and debug that first. So this
should have a run log.
View the task runs
and we can see something is failing,
so
a map function must return an object. Right.
Okay. Got it.
Let's edit this task. So that was
rather silly of me. Let's just return r.
Oh, the problem is the type inference knows
that this doesn't return r.
Can I just do that?
Why are you mourning?
Why are blocks so weird?
Does that work?
I really need to dig into that syntax
at some point.
Okay. It's based on operator between two expressions.
I just want to return r.
Let's be honest.
I'm not doing this a functional way, am
I? I'm actually I'm I know that I
think about it. I'm glad that it's yelling
at me.
Let's do the map
like we did for the downsampling.
Yeah. Being stupid.
Let's do our web desired
as equal to our
our value here
and then
filter
And
we want our desired.
I know I'm using different access or syntax
here.
I don't know why I just did that.
And then
for each record that fails,
we'll map over and send an alert.
And we're gonna do a post.
Even know how many of those I need.
So we got the JSON encodes
and URL
this
map
and return r.
Well, I've got everything wrong now. Alright. I
need extra one here.
I think that's me.
Oh, yes. I've got these two expressions again.
I think when you do
god.
I really need to just understand how the
blocking works, don't I?
Block.
So we can use
is.
So maybe okay. So if that means
object,
this
is block.
Wing it.
Alright.
So while we wait on that, hopefully, sending
an alert now. I'm gonna go try and
set threshold with the downsample data, so we
should start to see two different alerts coming
through,
which means that I want to now create
this threshold check, and I'm hoping I can
see
my deviation.
Good.
What do we need? Schedule
thirty seconds.
I'm
pretty sure I added
filter to the notifications.
Critical is when it is above
in fact, that's above zero. Right. Let's just
tell there aren't everything.
Obviously, we could
do this, but we wanna alert whenever a
deviated state goes goes too long.
So it's above good.
Normally I would, you know, we wouldn't run
this every thirty seconds.
Let's just try and make some noise here.
Okay. So
threshold check should be running. We have done
sample data. The alert is pending. Let's go
back to our task.
And aggregation is still working fine. This one's
failing. Is it still me? Is it something
I have done?
Cannot compile. Statement does nothing. Side effects are
not supported by the compiler.
User nothing.
What does nothing?
What is that?
I don't know why it formatting it like
that.
What does nothing? Is it the map?
Okay. Let's
our web
h t p
result.
I think this returns
something.
Oh, yeah. We need to
do that thingy.
I have no idea what I'm doing anymore.
K. So we've got 12344.
Back to the right brace, got right paren.
Am I not closing my r?
Okay.
So
12.
Boom.
Alright. Shop that side of the.
I don't know why I'm being rude to
my compiler.
Sorry.
Just anxious.
Why is my okay. So we're gonna come
back to this one in thirty seconds, so
I'm gonna go over here. I wanna know
why my threshold check
deviation
threshold
check,
has an alert to it.
So when changes oh, because it's when it
changes from okay to critical.
So I need to make that healthy.
So
make it healthy.
We'll come back to our dashboard.
Almost the exact same amount of time.
Healthy now. Okay. So
I want that to be healthy for thirty
seconds so that we get one threshold check
for passes. I mean, I could just have
updated the threshold check and said it doesn't
really matter. But let's try and do this
properly.
We're gonna make this fail again
momentarily.
I think that's been thirty seconds.
Boom, boom, boom.
We'll wait for this to fail.
Our box should still be sitting empty.
Come on computer. Do my bidding.
Yay.
Right.
So
while we're waiting,
let's view that deviation straight up rather than
calculating it so we can clean up this
dashboard now.
What we actually want to graph
is add on another filter.
Now it doesn't matter if you do these
all in one filter or multiple filters when
they're right next to each other.
Creative planner does understand what to do.
We want
what did I call it? Deviation.
There we go.
Aggregation,
we know it's working. We've just seen that
in the graph.
This should be doing a post.
Not yet.
When did the last run?
Right now,
Awesome.
I think it's alerted
quite a few times.
Oh, I've been alerted for the last five
minutes. Did I just not refresh the page?
I feel silly. Anyway, we now have our
alerting.
Which one is this? Actual desired and service
name. Actual desired service name.
So these are all of the alerts that
are being sent by the
task and not
the threshold
check.
So let's just
look at our
task
and that does the JSON encode with those
fields. So that's what we're seeing.
And our alert,
we should be getting a message that looks
like this.
It should be running every thirty seconds. It
has docker equals swarm and the value is
above zero.
What have I got wrong?
Rawkode equals swarm.
Alright. Let's just go Annie.
I just wanna see one come through.
So that should be triggering. Let's disable
this.
I want that. We still want this.
We still want this.
Docker
swarm
check.
Find query, we can see that it's failing.
Figure to check.
Value is above zero. Critical.
That's good.
What was that? Ah.
I'm breaking everything.
Why are you not sending threshold check?
Let's view the history. So we can see
well, we do definitely set the level to
critical.
And
let's view the history here.
There are no notifications.
Status goes from any to critical.
I wonder if I just didn't have it
okay enough. I guess critical to critical just
might be a rule
that doesn't trigger.
Double check.
Gonna cheat.
Let's wait for that to just pass.
I wanna see this to see
all good.
Alright. Okay. So now we've got a okay.
Back end,
and we'll see
zero.
And we will view the history,
and we will wait for it to return
to critical,
and we will get our notification.
Mental note, five second
run time.
Give me here my notification,
please.
Alright. Good.
And over here,
we're still getting nothing.
Well, that's also not working.
I don't know why it said no notification
here.
I mean, we quite clearly have sent notifications.
Last updated two minutes ago.
Why are you not last updated
now?
Just do it.
You know what? I'll fix it later. I
don't know what the problem there is.
And I've been streaming for a fair amount
of time, so I'm gonna call it quits
there.
What did we do? We
used Docker Swarm to deploy InfluxDB two.
We deployed Telegraph.
All of these
snippets of code, I know there's not much
in this particular example, but that's composed file
under telegraph.com
And I'll add a read me with the
two dashboards that I
applied from the community templates.
And I'll also export this
to YAML as well. These can all be
found on gitlab.com/rawcode/
influx d b -examples.
And there will be within the next ten
minutes, a Docker Swarm folder here.
Now I still think there's a lot of
work we can do with the Docker Swarm
dashboard.
I definitely think there are metrics in Telegraph
that we can try and find with regards
to image size, disk usage stuff.
Just the stuff that's not covered by the
Linux template, a lot of that is all
ready there,
particularly on this dashboard.
You know
oh, bucket. No.
Where did all my data go?
And FluxDB, you're letting me down today.
Yeah. So, you know, we do have this
decision on that there, but I would like
to see that as a breakdown
by images, particularly around it's putting down on
a tags, being able to identify, you know,
if you deploy the same image frequently.
Really useful to know how many different variations
of the tags are all across spread across
all of your swarm nodes and how much
disk space is being consumed, how quickly you
can clean that up. I think there's a
whole little bit of kind of just those
nice things that we can add, but I
will tackle that another time.
Thank you for joining me today. If you
have any questions, leave them in the comments.
Feel free to tweet me with ideas for
new things you want me to run through
with InfluxDB two, and I would be more
than happy to do that. Thank you very
much.